what up reject nation greg and john here
today we are going to catch up on the
doctor strange multiverse madness tv
spots and feature red that dropped this
week knowing our luck the time we upload
this another new tv spot has been
unveiled because that's the way marvel
rolls a lot of tv spots but it's
multiverse of madness we're clinging on
to every little bit we can't if you guys
can leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also uh subscribe click that
notification bell got a lot more crap
coming out this month alone as it is
let's get into it
[Music]
if you're watching doctor strange on a
screen this small
you're in the wrong universe definitely
set
oh that's a great shot yeah cinematics
then cinemark doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness get tickets now
see it in cinemark xd like that circle
pan shot i did what i had to do
to protect our world
it's pretty unfathomably exciting
where we're going in this film
it's the most fantastic new phase of
marvel
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories he believed it was
dangerous
in this story wow
different universes but unlocking the
multiverse creates a big pandora's box
you open the doorway and we don't know
who or what will walk through it
we're in unknown territory
we have rabies shots man
these other realities invite a plethora
of all these new characters
[Music]
was such a gigantic endeavor
it had to be large because it had to not
only paint a picture of our universe but
of multiple universes
we need your help it was a great
opportunity to pair two of the most
powerful superheroes together
that's going to be so good
tone to it and with sam remy at the helm
we wanted the fans to go oh how cool i
mean that really was that goal we wanted
to give the fans what they wanted just
cameos
no no cameos easter eggs and cameos
versions of himself
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] she looked like she was in one of
those glass prison
what if thingies
cubes yeah
this universe
twitter shot defender
your reckoning is long overdue
clear shot rachel mcadams christine
palmer tickets on sale now
oh wow dude
yeah
i got a lot of tickets for this one
all for yourself all for myself no one's
going to be able to go with me the
multiverse of greg's
man this last one showed a lot of good
new stuff yeah gotta slow down that shot
oh
yeah i saw this shot circulating on
social media of wanda walkie with the
ultron head that's pretty brutal
actually we slowed down that was a
pretty brutal shot
because the image alone was encapsulated
enough as it is with the yellow behind
her the mist because it's an ultra
headache covered in blood that's the
freaking elizabeth olsen she's got that
confidence ready to kill walk well and
it seems like we'll actually get to have
at least some of that like intensity
like it looks like oil rather than blood
so i feel like we might actually get a
little more splatter and a little more
that sam raimi grossness in there too i
mean it's probably the oil splat from
the ultron bots but just that level of
control and menace in her performance i
love it and yeah you know the more
footage we see the more this really does
start to shape up to feel like an actual
sam raimi film which is the thing that
actually gets me the most excited about
this in a lot of ways and we're all
looking forward to seeing the cameos and
such don't get me wrong i am very much
so however it's just what always has me
a little bit concerned specifically
regarding sam raimi himself is when he
does like the big hollywood blockbusters
it seems like there's two different sam
raymonds and we were just talking about
this recently there's a sam raimi film
and then there's the sam remy who does
the big movies you know yeah and sam
raimi who's gonna come on and make sure
that everything gets done on time and
maybe he'll do a couple scenes in his
style but for the most part he probably
just needs money to finance another one
of his own movies but a lot of the great
shots they're leading with here feel
very much like kevin feige let sam raimi
do his thing so much of the time and
there were some revealing moments in
here as well that i i noticed like there
was that shot that's been in the
trailers a bunch where doctor strange is
looking at the city and it's got that i
don't know dissipating oily
yeah
it seems like that shop might actually
just be a another one of his vision
nightmarish sequences
because there was another shot in the
trailer where yeah it's it cuts to what
looks like a normal looking version of
new york city
and it's not actually uh in ruins so i
wonder how much like premonition dealing
it's gonna be here he's in free city at
the end
nice version of it the more shots we see
of defender strange in this one moment
with america chavez the more it looks
like defender strange is probably going
to die in this one specific scene there
is that desperate harrowing effect that
just seems like this will be the scene
that he actually dies and actually in
the future right of it i think they had
another shot here that showed us more of
them running through it this is the
visuals this looks freaking insane yeah
it looks like they absolutely had carte
blanche to get as imaginative as as they
wanted to and like it almost reminds me
of like this whole movie's taking place
in the vortex from army of darkness or
something like that you know paul
bettany was actually on i believe
stephen colbert recently and he was
asked if he's going to be returning in
this and he gave one of his coy answers
of
yeah i'm not talking about koi jonjo a
regular guest here in the channel
talking about the word meaning koi he
was coy in the fact of how one of those
i i plead the fifth answers you know i
can't convert
werewolves i'm not the ship of course
yes well we don't know if he's gonna be
in this movie or not i mean there hasn't
been many rumors circulating that he
would be in here i imagine that with the
fact that you see tommy and billy in a
specific trailer obviously you're going
to be going to seeing other wandas as
well at least that's what the trailer
alludes to and considering wanda's
motive here in the film seems to be so
much about attaining her family again it
does make me wonder if white vision will
return in this movie and actually pay
that thing off in one division it'd be
pretty cool because you can easily
explain some of the events of wanda
vision and some of the backstory to set
up who our character of wanda is at this
particular point in time for those who
haven't seen one division but to include
white vision in here would mean the only
way to understand what's going on if
you've seen the show yeah yeah
absolutely that'd be the most like
tethered i think uh from movie to show
so far with the mcu well maybe they'll
finally do like what john campbell was
talking about this morning and put it
previously on in front of the movie so
that anybody who skipped one division
will be caught yeah
because it makes perfect sense that he
would show up somewhere especially with
his as personal of a story as this looks
like it'll be for wanda and for her
power sets you know consequences on the
universe like you've got to see paul
benny in there somewhere
oh guys
yeah this [ __ ] looks so good and i'm
glad that
i know we didn't really cover leaks on
this one so
we're only a couple weeks away it's
gonna be actual surprises legit surprise
extra surprises in the movie
awesome yeah all right guys well thank
you so much for being here with us uh
subscribe and keep a look out for when
uh our review for doctor strange is up
catch you guys soon
[Music]